>> Tucker: HERE IN
WASHINGTON OUR LEADERS SPENT
THE WEEK FOCUSED ON THE
MIDDLE EAST IN IRAN.
OUT THERE IN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY THERE ARE PLENTY OF
MORE PRESSING TANGIBLE
CONCERNS.
FOR EXAMPLE, MANY OF OUR
CITIES ARE STARTING TO FAIL.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AGING BOTH
CRIME AND THE COST OF LIVING
ARE SURGING AND LEFT WING
PROSECUTORS HAVE STOPPED
ENFORCING THE LAW.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON ALL OF
THAT IN PART 4 OF OUR
AMERICA DISTOPIA SERIES IN
JUST A MOMENT.
FOR THE LEADING PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE CANDIDATE JOE
BIDEN OF DELAWARE.
NONE OF THESE PROBLEMS
MATCHES WHAT HE BELIEVES IS
THE GREATEST CRISIS AT ALL.
AMERICA ISN'T IMPORTING
ENOUGH DESPERATELY POOR
PEOPLE.
ON A TWEET JANUARY 5TH BIDEN
LASHED OUT AT THE PRESIDENT
FOR IMMIGRATION POLICY
QUOTE:  OUR STATUE OF
LIBERTY INVITES IN THE
TIRED, THE MORE HUDDLED
MASSES YEARNING TO BREATHE
FREE DONALD TRUMP HAS
SLAMMED THE DOOR IN THE FACE
OF FAMILIES FLEEING
PERSECUTION AND VIOLENCE.
END QUOTE.
DEMORALIZED THAT JOE BIDEN.
THEN A FEW MONTHS AGO BIDEN
VOWED IF WHEN HE BECOMES
PRESIDENT HE WILL ADMIT
2 MILLION MORE IMMIGRANTS
OVERNIGHT AND INCREASE THAT
NUMBER FROM THERE.
WATCH WE CAN AFFORD TO TAKE
IN 2 MILLION PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THAT IN A COUNTRY
OF 330 MILLION PEOPLE CANNOT
ABSORB PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED AND WHO ARE
JUSTIFIABLY FLEEING
OPPRESSION IS ABSOLUTELY
BIZARRE.
ABSOLUTELY BIZARRE.
I WOULD ALSO MOVE TO
INCREASE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
IMMIGRANTS ABLE TO COME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY OF THOSE
IMMIGRANTS WILL BE STAYING
AT JOE BIDEN'S HOUSE AT JOE
BIDEN'S EXPENSE.
[ZERO.
OUR CHIEF MISSION AS A
NATION S. TO ADMIT AS MANY
POOR PEOPLE AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN THE LESS IMPRESSIVE
THEIR COUNTRY OF ORIGIN THE
LESS THEY ARE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS COUNTRY
THE MORE WE WANT THEM.
YOU ARE RICH.
THEY ARE POOR.
THEREFORE YOU MUST GIVE THEM
MONEY, A RIGHT TO VOTE A
PERMANENT HOME.
ONCE HAVE YOU DONE THAT
REPEAT.
BIDEN CLAIMS THAT'S OUR
MORAL DUTY, THAT DONALD
TRUMP AND ANYONE ELSE WHO
SHIRKS THAT DUTY IS A
RACIST.
BUT, IS TRUMP SHIRKING THAT
DUTY?
IS THE BASIC CLAIM EVEN
TRUE?
IT'S WORTH ASSESSING.
SO MUCH LYING.
SO ONCE AGAIN WE GO TO THE
NUMBERS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY ARE.
FROM OCTOBER 2018 TO
SEPTEMBER OF 2019, THE
BORDER PATROL APPREHENDED
977,000 PEOPLE AT THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST TOTAL IN
MORE THAN A DECADE AND MORE
THAN THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS
COMBINED.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND THAT'S
JUST PEOPLE BEING CAUGHT AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
MANY MORE GETTING THROUGH
WITHOUT GETTING CAUGHT.
AND TENS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WHO
ENTER LEGALLY AND OVERSTAY
VISAS.
THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TETHERING THEMSELVES HERE
WITH MILLIONS OF ANCHOR
BABIES.
THAT'S NOT A TALKING POINT.
THAT'S A FACT.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
IMMIGRATION STUDIES, FOR
EXAMPLE, 372,000 CHILDREN OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS WERE BORN IN
THIS COUNTRY JUST LAST YEAR.
EVERY ONE OF THEM IS NOW AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN AND THEIR
PARENTS ARE BENEFITING FROM
A WHOLE SUITE OF BENEFITS.
FOOD STAMPS, MEDICAID, OTHER
PROGRAMS.
OF COURSE THEY WON'T BE
DEPORTED NOW.
I WONDER HOW WE GOT
22 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS?
THAT'S HOW.
SO, BY ANY ACTUAL MEASURE,
BY THE DATA, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IS WORSE THAN IT
HAS BEEN IN A LONG TIME.
BUT FOR JOE BIDEN, STILL NOT
ENOUGH.
22 MILLION ILLEGALS?
WHY NOT 30 MILLION OR
50 MILLION?
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM GETS
FREE HEALTHCARE PAID FOR BY
YOU.
THAT'S HIS PROMISE.
IS YOUR COUNTRY REALLY SO
SPECTACULARLY RICH THAT WE
CAN AFFORD THIS?
AND, OF COURSE YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER.
WE ARE NOT A RICH COUNTRY.
WE ARE MORE THAN
$20 TRILLION IN DEBT.
OUR MIDDLE CLASS IS DYING.
IN PART BECAUSE IMMIGRANTS
WILLING TO WORK FOR LESS
HAVE DRIVEN DOWN WAGES.
IT DOESN'T MAKE THE
IMMIGRANTS BAD.
THEY ARE COMING FROM
INCREDIBLY POOR PLACES WITH
TOTALLY DIFFERENT STANDARDS
OF LIVING.
IT'S ECONOMIC FACT WHEN YOU
FLOOD THE LABOR POOL WITH
PEOPLE WILLING TO WORK FOR
LESS, WAGES GO DOWN.
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, AMERICA'S
MOST IMMIGRANT HEAVY STATE,
CALIFORNIA, IS ALSO THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED.
MANY PEOPLE BORN IN
CALIFORNIA CAN'T LEAVE
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
ASK IDAHO AND TEXAS.
JOE BIDEN SAYS WE NEED MORE.
ACCORDING TO BIDEN, OUR
COUNTRY IS A SANCTUARY MUST
BE A SANCTUARY FOR THOSE
FLEEING VIOLENCE.
BUT BECAUSE JOE BIDEN KNOWS
NOTHING, HE IS NOT AWARE
THAT SOME OF AMERICA'S
CITIES ARE DEADLIER THAN THE
PLACES THOSE PEOPLE ARE
FLEEING FROM.
FOR EXAMPLE, EL SALVADOR,
1/3 OF ALL LIVING EL
SALVADORANS LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY NOW.
HERE ARE THE NUMBERS.
SALVATORE HAS 50 MURDERS PER
100,000 PEOPLE.
LAST YEAR BALTIMORE, NOT A
COUNTRY, THE CITY IN
MARYLAND, BALTIMORE HAD 51
PER 100,000.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S MORE
DANGEROUS THAN EL SALVADOR.
BALTIMORE CLEARLY HASN'T
BENEFITED AT ALL FROM
AMERICA'S POLICY OF
UNLIMITED IMMIGRATION.
NONE OF THIS MATTERS BECAUSE
FOR PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN
AND THE REST OF THIS
COUNTRY'S RULING CLASS
HELPING AMERICAN CITIZENS,
STOPPING THE POINT A LONG
TIME AGO.
THE POINT IS GETTING
REELECTED AND FEELING
VIRTUOUS.
WELL, SPEAKING OF IN 2018
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY CHEF GOT
NATIONAL ATTENTION BY
WARNING ILLEGAL ALIENS IN
HER CITY ABOUT IMPENDING
FEDERAL ICE RAID.
>> IT IS A CONTINUED
PERPETUATION OF A RACIST LIE
THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT
VALUED MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY.
WE IN OAKLAND KNOW BETTER.
WE IN OAKLAND HAVE A
COMMUNITY THAT WELCOMES AND
HONORS ALL PEOPLE, NO MATTER
WHERE THEY CAME FROM OR HOW
THEY GOT HERE.
>> Tucker: OH, SHE IS AN
INCREDIBLY GOOD PERSON
UNLIKE YOU, RACIST.
THANKS TO LEBANONY SHERIFF'S
THANKS TO LEBANONY  LERIFF'S
THANKS TO LEBANONY  LIBIFF'S
THANKS TO LEBANONY  LIBBYF'S
THANKS TO LEBANONY  LIBBY'SS
THANKS TO LEBANONY  LIBBY'S EFFR
THANKS TO LEBANONY  LIBBY'S EFFS
SEVERAL OAKLAND CAME A TOP
HAVEN FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
RUNNING FROM THE LAW.
ONE OF THOSE IMMIGRANTS HAS
NOW TAKEN A LIFE.
ACCORDING TO POLICE MADISON
SUZANNE WHITECARE WAS
MURDERED BY ROBERT MARTINEZ
IN A ROAD RAGE INCIDENT LAST